almost everybody I know can afford a
smartphone but not many people out there
can afford to spend two three thousand
dollars on a dedicated DSLR and then on
top of that another couple thousand
dollars per lens as well this idea
really got me thinking can you become a
modern-day influencer or business
entrepreneur in 2019 by only using a
smartphone well there's only one way to
find out what's going on guys my name is
David Tomic and welcome back to the channel
I know I'm wearing white today not your
traditional black but hey you go try
something new every now and again
alright today we're going to be
comparing a flagship samsung phone
against the canon 6d a go around the
home today just taking a generic photos
of little bits and pieces just to really
try push both the cameras potential
we've looked at lights darks shadows and
everything in between really to see how
much we can get out of each device and
how much dynamic range is possible but
if these have been shot raw so the
Samsung has a feature that lets you put
all your photos into raw when you're
shooting in pro mode which is fantastic
when you're comparing it against the
DSLR because that's the main perk really
of using a big camera versus just a
little old phone after taking and
editing six photos on each device it's
actually really tricky to tell which
ones which I'm going to pop both
pictures on each screen right now and
show you the difference and let you guys
decide which ones which okay so the
first two images are just a generic
clock on the wall one of them is the
Samsung and one of them is the Canon you
really can't tell with these two the
only thing that gives it away is the
blacks the second image is a close-up of
a leaf it's actually one of the hardest
out of all the six pictures to select
which one it is at the end of this video
I'm also going to put in a quick behind
the scenes how I edited this these two
particular photos so you can really get
an understanding of what they started
out as before they were edited to kind
of be a side-by-side comparison in
really tell where the Samsung starts to
fall apart this image was originally
very overexposed
you can tell that with the Samsung you
can't bring those highlights back as
much as you're able to in the DSLR the
same thing happens with a watch photo
it's just the reverse effect the shadows
really start to fall away and the black
start to get very grainy and pixilated
whereas with the DSLR you can tell it's
still crisp it's clean there's not that
much noise in the photo and you can
really draw out those shadows without
taking away from the image quality again
another photo that you really struggle
with to tell the difference with
straight away I'd might think that the
left photo here is the Samsung because
it's oversaturated and a little bit more
powerful but I edited it that way in
particular just to kind of draw your eye
away and confuse you a little bit but if
you really look up in the top right hand
corner of this photo where the sky is
you're gonna tell that the right one is
actually a samsung and that's where it
starts to fall away in the shadows and
the highlights and finally the last
image I actually have to give it to the
Samsung because it performed very very
well this was done with a selective
focus mode on the Samsung to give you
more of a depth of field because the
lens I was using on the camera was a F
2.8 1635 millimeter lens which gives it
a nice bokeh but regardless the Samsung
still came out the clear winner because
the original DSLR photo is a little bit
more warped at 35 millimetres so what's
the conclusion do you really have to go
out and spend a couple thousand dollars
buying a brand new DSLR or can you start
a business in 2019 using just a
smartphone well in my personal opinion I
truly do believe that you can run a
business in 2019 only using a flagship
smartphone be it the brand new Samsung
s10 or the iPhone XR or any models a
couple years old they all have pretty
good hardware and software all built
into the phones to really be able to
help you design shoot and post great
photos time and time again to really
give you guys a good idea of the two
editing styles of these two devices I
want to show you the Samsun on the left
and the DSLR on the right so let's take
the screen shrink it down and pop it in
that little corner there and let me show
you
on the big screen so if we start playing
these two videos here we're going to
notice that both of the colors
straightaway are completely different
the Samsung on the left is a lot more
vibrant and a lot more typical Samsung
oversaturated whereas the cannon itself
has come out more natural looking versus
the original photo on the left if you
vent ever really wondered how I edit my
photos or how most people actually in
2019 edit those vibrant happy lusty
looking photos for Instagram this is a
very particular editing style on
Lightroom that can be done in well under
a couple minutes actually so the main
things you really want to focus on here
is your highlights shadows your whites
and blacks and also your contrast but
then working with the s-curve to try to
get things as close to as natural as
possible now the reason I selected this
photo here to use as my prime example is
because the sampling actually comes out
looking significantly better than the
DSLR I'm not sure if I just didn't take
enough time to get the settings right on
the Canon or if Samsung really can do a
much better job because it was taken at
a much closer distance that's one of the
great things about the Samsung is it has
the macro lens inbuilt as well whereas
it dinner Salar you're gonna actually
have to invest in a separate macro lens
that's it from me guys if you liked the
video remember I'm posting brand new
econ related videos every Monday so make
sure you smash that subscribe button
20-19 style and I'll see you in the next
one